[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vous tenez le bras
ah bah oui ça fait un petit moment qu'on
n'a pas été un sens
quand j cela m est arrivé dans cette
unité protégée de l'hôpital de gloire
elle était très agité et désorienté
attentes de la maladie d'alzheimer à est
aujourd'hui très réceptive à ce chat
thérapeutique aux jeunes et à la
maison
c'est un chat un peu particulier un
robot qui reproduit les sons et les
geysers de l'année on
[Musique]
veut te faire même un peu le schéma
là on était dix lendemain en fait pour
l'apaiser parce que cette dame elle
tient pas en place
mais si
on est là à côté d'elle local on n'est
pas stressé
[Musique]
voilà elle elle communique
ça déclenche et l'émotion chez elle des
souvenirs à lui j'ai un chat un chat
chez eux ou
[Musique]
les ventres dont on rentre dans son
monde en fait on est dans sa dimension
dans l'est dans sa bulle si
malheureusement parce qu'elle est
réclament qu'ils aient dit lundi
convaincu des bienfaits de la présence
de vrais animaux pour ces patients ce
gériatre vont accueillir dans le jardin
de l'hôpital au printemps
[Musique]
la médiation par l'animal est encore
rare dans les hôpitaux mais elle est de
plus en plus pratiquée dans les
établissements médico sociaux
ophélie fulbert est éducatrice
spécialisée
depuis deux ans elle sillonne les routes
avec ces petits animaux est ce que vous
voulez car et ses pralines pour lui dire
bonjour
est-ce que c'est doux oui ils ont
l'habitude vous savez ils ont l'habitude
de venir voir du monde c'est sa deuxième
séance de médiation par l'animal elle
est douce on sent que dans cet ehpad de
saint-dié sur loire
qu'on a toujours un petit schéma de
séances qui se déroulent avec le temps
de présentation des animaux
le temps de nourrissage des animaux
après on a le petit temps que j'appelais
le temps cocooning mon propose aux
personnes d'avoir les animaux sur leurs
genoux de les brosser
si l'animal est d'accord bien sûr et
puis après on a un temps d'activités
ludiques assisté par l'animal là qui est
vraiment si ciblées en fonction des
personnes aussi donc à travers chacune
de ses activités l'idée c'est qu'on va
toujours essayer de pouvoir stimuler
certaines compétences et de travailler
autour des objectifs qu'on définit
en l'écoutant normalement coupe bien les
vinyles mais il ne coupe pas les doigts
vous les découper encore un petit peu
non c'est bon comme ça vous avez des
coupés plusieurs morceaux bravo vous me
regardez
moi celui là
faut faire quand même preuve de
motricité fine pour découper les
aliments ensuite faut faire preuve de
douceur quand faut les brosses et enfin
donc niveau motricité c'est énorme
niveau mémoire aussi parce que du coup
il y en a beaucoup directement qui
associe ça alors à leurs souvenirs ont
fait ensemble la
voilà super
vous aviez des baux lapin
il était plus gros que ça je pense un
parce que là c'est vraiment des tout
petits lapins
là vous aviez des petits aussi c'est
vraiment un travail de mémoire de juste
à travers le souvenir en fait et c'est
inestimable
elle vous plait celle là
ça y est vous pouvez le brosser
attendait regardez
qu'est ce que vous dites
ils savent bien qu'on les aime oui ce
qui me saute aux yeux ça va être ce
qu'ils ont tendance à être plutôt
apathique se renfermer ou qui pour
certaines animations vont être plutôt
dans une passivité et qui hélas au
travers de la médiation animale sont
vraiment hyper présent en fait vraiment
dans l'instant présent
je trouve que c'est ça nous apporte
aussi à nous en tant qu'équipe parce que
justement c'est quand on voit les
résidents qui tout d'un coup s'ouvrent
et son autre hyper heureux eh ben tu
vois il ya encore des ressources et
encore des choses des accroches en fait
ça nous fait du bien voilà
en voiture mais lolo
comme ophélie de plus en plus
d'éducateurs ou soignants se spécialise
en médiation par l'animal pour mieux
accompagner les personnes dépendantes ou
en situation de handicap ou ça fait du
bien ça
on aime ça les gratouilles fait du bien
tiens ma peine
c'est le cas de sophie rousseau à
villedômer en indre et loire elle a été
éducatrice pendant vingt ans dans un
foyer de vie je me retrouvais toujours
avec les personnes handicapées par
contre je ne me retrouvais plus on
travaille en institution voulait pouvoir
leur apporter autre chose à notre
accompagnement fait et je me suis aperçu
que le contact à animal ça allait
beaucoup de bienfaits sas a rassuré ça a
donné de la confiance en soi
voilà ça a aidé à aller de l'avant
voilà faut juste que tu es un petit peu
c'est pour ces moments là que sophie
s'est formé à la médiation par l'animal
appelé à créer sa ferme goulcester
diamaré oui parce que tu es bien venir
ici oui pour toi parce que j'aime bien
les lapins pourquoi qui amena les lapins
pigeons très jeune fille ils sont très
mignons
qui lui donne et wapol
accroche-toi va regarder ça à l'air
d'être un gros mot celui-ci s'appelle
kenzo lui alors tu prends tu prends bien
que nous aurons le bout de la feuille
voilà et il lui tend à faut que tu
t'approches et et voit la super mais
c'est pas mal ça c'est très bien est ce
qu'il ya une petite caresse et avant une
petite caresse ouais
parfois les personnes il ya des choses
que elles ne savent pas faire au
quotidien et avec les animaux elles vont
être capables de les mettre en place
parce que l'animal stimule l'animal
donne envie de se dépasser la médiation
par l'animal est efficace quand les
séances sont régulières notamment avec
les personnes autistes ces jeunes
résidents de l'iem de naveil sophie les
connaît bien elle les accueille dans sa
ferme depuis quatre ans
j'essaye de les mettre en contact avec
les animaux
comme tout ce qui est sensorielle ça
fonctionne bien le toucher c'est très
intéressant au niveau des émotions donc
j'essaye de les amener à toucher les
animaux
donc à voir si tu peux le faire
j'avais fait un bisou
les personnes autistes souvent elles
sont du mal avec le regard à regarder
dans les yeux dans les choses alors que
là sont intéressés par les animaux donc
elles arrivent à travailler un peu le
regard ça leur permet aussi d'être dans
le plaisir de travailler et ça peut
permettre de travailler mieux en classe
ou ou ailleurs la séance dure une heure
et demie chaque contact physique est une
victoire donc
une caresse énergique
avec les enfants autistes
les équidés sont d'excellents médiateur
parce qu'ils ont les mêmes modes de
communication ils vivent dans l'instant
présent il ne juge pas la médiation
équine est aussi de plus en plus utilisé
avec les personnes souffrant de la
maladie d'alzheimer elle nous avait
accueillis la semaine dernière
bonjour j'ai une mémoire très courte
ok vous profitez de l'instant
clémence chapeau a été infirmière dans
un ehpad après une formation de 16 mois
cette cavalière est devenu médiatrice
équine alors qu'est ce qu'on va faire
aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui je sais port alors ce que
moi ce que je vous propose aujourd'hui
c'est d'aller vous occuper d'un cheval
il s'appelle pepita une fois par semaine
elle emmène ses anciens patients dans ce
centre équestre du loiret
du coup ça vous rappelle des choses mais
oui absolument
parce que derrière la maison kabyle et
mes parents y avait un pré où l'on était
des aliments comme vous l'avez vu
christiane où il va beaucoup de
souvenirs avec les émotions qui vont
avec oui voilà ça permet oui c'était un
prêt
si vous étiez très proche de
goethe a permis aussi de mobiliser des
capacités comme la marche ça m'attriste
et il est improbable
ça c'était pas dans les moeurs du
pib est comme des enfants droit prochain
on a eu tout à fait ainsi
que ça me prend la caméra
et du coup de de favoriser l'expression
des émotions et de ressenti elle nous
avions
sont capitaux
je ne sais pas je vous présente ses
pépites à au milieu ne vous fait pas
peur non du tout donc vous avez envie
d'y aller ouais je vous ai monté à
cheval mois ya trois ans je viens monter
sur mon cheval
j'ai une photo d'ailleurs de ça quel
grand moment
contact du cheval chrestia mais annie se
sentent bien ils médias
l'animal est un miroir de leurs émotions
ils les valorise
le temps de cette séance elles ne sont
plus des patientes elles deviennent les
soignantes de pepita
j'ai toujours aimé les chevaux
mais malheureusement il n'y avait pas de
haras dans la région kabyle qui est en
jeu n'est ce n'est que depuis
je veux dire deux mois que je lié visite
et qu'est ce que ça vous fait de cette
un vrai régal
[Musique]
on
et
oui
la nuit est ce que vous avez passé un
bon moment ah oui excellent
ok j'ai vu ainsi d'un moment
je suis pour elle je veux des coups bas
c'est un mois égoïste
merci de le partager avec moi en tout
cas peut-être avec des chevaux qu'est ce
que ça vous fait vous le sentiment de
liberté
et le respect
le choeur apaisé les angoisses ont volé
christiane thérèse annie vont retrouver
leur lieu de vie
elles auront peut-être oublié dans une
heure ou dans quelques jours qu'elles
sont venues ici mais les émotions elles
resteront un
merci à l'aide du de burgos l'oeil
gravé dans leur mémoire abîmée